We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here is a fair question about Joe Biden.
And it sort of relates to our conversation
earlier.
Let's take a listen to it.
David, I just want to know, what were your
main critiques of Biden policy?
I just wanted to know the guy into the 2020
election knowing, like, what do you disagree
with him on?
Thank you, God.
OK.
So listen, there is no way to sum this up
in one segment, but every time I've done an
analysis of a Joe Biden proposal, Joe Biden's
health care proposal, Joe Biden's tax plan.
Joe Biden on climate or whatever else, I will
point out where he falls short.
And I think what's important here is context.
So, for example, Joe Biden's tax plan is actually
quite solid and a lot of very good things
in it.
It doesn't, for example, create new higher
tax brackets.
I think we need right now the highest tax
bracket, I think is around five hundred and
fifty thousand dollars.
We probably need tax brackets like at the
one point five or two million dollar level.
Five or 10 million.
Fifteen hundred.
You know, but we need higher levels and higher
tax rates at those higher levels.
He doesn't do that.
That's a critique of Joe Biden's tax plan.
And Joe Biden's tax plan does a lot of good
things.
When we looked at Joe Biden's clean energy
and climate change plan, it does many good
things, but it fell short in some areas in
terms of certain requirements, pollution requirements.
As you know, I outlined them in that clip
when we've talked about Joe Biden on health
care.
Joe Biden's plan will give way more people
access to health care and it will make health
care affordable for way more people.
But it's not going to be comprehensive and
universal.
As an example.
So with all of these questions, the reason
I'm doing this is that's it feels to me that
that voicemail was a good faith question.
It was not a question meant to do this stuff
of if it's not Bernie, then who cares if it's
Trump?
It seems like it's just I'm curious, where
do you disagree with Joe Biden?
And I disagree with Joe Biden in many areas.
And yet the reality that I must vote for Joe
Biden is not missed at any point in time.
And it is abundantly and completely clear.
And my critiques of Joe Biden have not been
done in a way to even remotely suggest maybe
we stay home or vote for Trump.
Joe Biden's plans don't do everything that
we want them to do.
Taking the Senate in November, in addition
to winning the White House, would best enable
us to have two straight years, two solid years
during which we can push the Senate and the
House and Joe Biden to pass as much progressive
change as possible.
And that's all we can really say right now.
And so my goal from here on out is I have
no problem critiquing Joe Biden's policy where
it falls short and that's what I do.
If I wasn't doing that, I really would be
doing you a disservice.
But I'm not going to do it in a way that might
leave anybody thinking, whoa, is David sort
of saying maybe we don't vote for by now?
I'm not going to do that.
It's going to be made clear in every single
segment that that's what has to happen.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Now, I actually.
I don't know.
Pat had a very interesting incident over the
weekend, and I wanted to talk to you about
it.
Although I don't know that we're doing it
today.
So we may have some very interesting stories
on the bonus show today about golden Bitcoin
prices spiking and Trump's executive order
on drug prices and some other things.
Or we may have a wacky Pat Ford story from
the weekend that I think you're really, really
going to love.
But I'm just not sure yet because I've got
to figure out which bonus show we're doing
today.
In any case, get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member at join Pacman dot
com or becoming a patron at Patrie on dot
com slash David package.
We'll see you then.